Reality warpers.
Real pieces of work, aren’t they?
It’s one thing when an anomaly is all claws
and fangs, like SCP-682, or if their attack
of choice is snapping necks like SCP-173,
but it’s an entirely different story if
an anomaly can turn the air you breathe into
chocolate pudding or shove you into a pocket
dimension that looks almost like our own reality,
except everyone is just a walking, talking
pile of spiders.
See what I mean?
Reality warpers, real handfuls.
Though, of course, not all reality warpers
are created equal.
Some are relatively weak, only affecting the
world around them in a mild, ambient fashion.
Others can rattle whole dimensions with their
tremendous power.
The same also goes for morality.
Some reality warpers are loving and benevolent,
such as SCP-343, the kindly, old all-powerful
being known to some as God.
And some are pure evil beings who want nothing
more than to use their immense power to sow
chaos and misery among everyone else.
And personally, we can’t think of a better
example of the latter than Bill Cipher from
Gravity Falls.
This Demonic Dorito wants nothing more than
to take over our dimension and rebuild it
in his image of absolute insanity.
So naturally, we started wondering: If these
two reality-warping titans, SCP-343 and Bill
Cipher, ever came to blows, who would win?
We were so curious, In fact, that we fired
up the Anom-O-Tron 6000, our state-of-the-art
simulation supercomputer, to see how exactly
the two might meet and how their epic battle
would play out.
Who do you think would take the coveted W
on this one?
Let us know down in the comments, along with
any other out of universe What If situations
you’d love to see.
But in the meantime, let’s fire up the machine.
Be warned, folks: It’s gonna get weird.
The date was July 12th, 2013.
For SCP-343, it had started out as a relatively
normal day.
He’d spent the night playing solitaire on
the astral plane, before warping back into
his humanoid containment cell by morning,
leaving the Foundation none the wiser.
After all, he was really here voluntarily.
If the Foundation had truly wanted to try
to confine him here, they were welcome to
give it a go, but it would be about as effective
as trying to catch a whisper in a butterfly
net.
While God had come to this place to experience
the joyful illusion of giving up control,
it truly was little more than an illusion
to him.
If he wanted to, he could exterminate the
SCP Foundation in less than an afternoon,
then retire to Burger King for a Whopper.
So really, they’re all just lucky he’s
a benevolent being, more interested in hanging
out than dispensing wrath on those he perceived
as insolent.
That was the Old Testament him.
He’d done a lot of soul searching and growth
since then.
It’d been at least a millennium since he’d
smote anyone, for that matter, and the last
guy really had it coming.
However, today was going to be a little different.
God knew that something was going to happen
today.
He sensed a great source of energy emerging.
Something dark and malevolent.
He sighed and closed his eyes for a moment,
focusing himself.
He knew, whatever the nature of this threat,
it would fall upon him to face and destroy
it.
How irritating.
He was hoping to finally binge Stranger Things
Season 4 today...
Elsewhere in Site 19, things seemed to be
inordinately peaceful.
There hadn’t been any containment breaches
or new anomalies brought in.
There hadn’t been any attacks from rival
Groups of Interest.
Dr. Bright hadn’t even done anything stupid
or started any fires.
To borrow an old cliché, it was quiet.
Too quiet.
Perhaps the only person who wasn’t having
a relatively mellow day was Security Officer
Frederick Simmons, a mid-level guard who’d
been stationed at Site 19 for four years now.
He just wasn’t feeling himself today...
The work didn’t bother Simmons - emotionally,
at least.
Typically, even after seeing rather traumatic
things or being in near-death situations while
in containment breaches, it hadn’t left
any lingering effects.
But lately, he’d been having the strangest
dreams...
It always played out the same way.
Shortly after going to sleep, he’d open
his eyes in a strange, multi-colored void,
surrounded by bizarre, seemingly random floating
objects, none of which seemed to have any
real relevance to him or his life.
And just when he’d begin to question it,
the other recurring element of the dream would
occur.
Out of the shimmering, oil-slick rainbow of
mind-boggling colors, a strange being would
suddenly emerge.
A glowing golden triangle, almost like a drawing
of a pyramid, with a stove pipe hat, a little
bow tie, thin black arms and legs, and most
notable of all, a single large eye with a
slit pupil staring out from the center.
The eye almost seemed to have a strange, hypnotic
quality to it.
Simmons felt bewitched whenever he looked
into it.
He wasn’t afraid.
Quite the opposite, actually.
For reasons he couldn’t understand, this
strange creature from the world of dreams
seemed like a good friend of his.
He said, “Well, well, well, well, if it
isn’t my number one guy, the Fredmeister,
in the house!
I’ve missed you.
Have you missed me?
Put her there, good buddy!”
The entity extended his hand, and Simmons
shook it.
The Foundation guard could feel a strange
tingling sensation jolting down his arm.
The first time Simmons had encountered the
entity, he’d told him his name: Bill Cipher,
and he’d told him how incredibly important
it was that Simmons kept their little nighttime
meetings a secret.
In exchange, Bill was here to listen.
Simmons would spend his time in the mindscape
pouring out his worries and frustrations with
his daily work, as Bill paid impeccable attention.
The strange little dream entity seemed fascinated
by the work Simmons did - All the peculiar
and wondrous anomalies he guarded at Site
19.
But to Simmons, it was all just boring work.
Zombie-creating supernatural plague doctors
and immortal men with metal limbs lose their
shine after you see them day in, day out,
for years on end.
Frankly, Simmons needed a day off, but he’d
already used up all his PTO when he’d gotten
the flu earlier that year.
He just didn’t know what to do.
Luckily for him, Bill had a solution.
Bill, as it turned out, had a fancy little
ability: He could occupy the body of a human
being, and operate it for them.
Bill could take the wheel while Simmons took
a load off in the mindscape.
How hard could standing around, pretending
to look busy at the SCP Foundation really
be?
As Bill explained the offer to him, Simmons
couldn’t see any flaws in his reasoning
- After all, Bill was a friend.
Why would he have any ill will towards him?
With that, he shook hands with the bizarre
supernatural triangle, and felt the sudden,
rough sensation of having his consciousness
ripped free from his body, only for Bill to
slither in and take his place.
This new Simmons - The Bill-occupied Simmons
- opened up his demonic, yellow eyes, and
grinned.
He gave a demented laugh to Simmons’ floated,
disembodied soul.
“Oh man,” he said, wiping away a tear
of laughter with Simmons’ finger.
“That was too easy!
With your body, I can use the SCP Foundation’s
technology to take over the multiverse!
See ya, sucker!”
And with one last demented chuckle, Bill left
for work at the SCP Foundation, with Simmons
being the latest in his long line of meat
puppets.
After arriving at Site 19, he sneaked through
the facility, knowing exactly where he needed
to be.
You see, Bill is a native entity of the second
dimension - the world of flat shapes - but
he’s able to access the minds of beings
in the third dimension, like us, through the
medium of the mindscape, rather than the physical
realm.
Bill’s life goal has always been to find
a way to permeate and take over the third
dimension, turning it into his personal playground.
All he needed was the right anomaly to bring
him forth into our world.
In this case, a little anomalous device favored
by Dr. Kain Pathos Crow: SCP-158, also known
as The Soul Extractor.
While Dr. Crow left to the courtyard for his
evening walkies, the being that most people
assumed was Fred Simmons secreted himself
into SCP-158’s containment chamber and locked
the door behind him.
He didn’t have much time; he’d need to
do this perfectly if he wanted a real chance
at taking over the universe.
He was amused by the irony, at least.
The fact that, in order to take over, he’d
need to sneak into the midst of the people
most likely to destroy him.
Still, where’s the fun in a life with no
risk?
At SCP-158’s control console, he inputted
the data to soul extraction and set a timer.
However, there was one difference between
this and the usual procedures performed with
the Soul Extractor: There was no containment
receptacle on the other end.
Whatever was extracted would just be released
into the world.
And this was exactly what Bill was counting
on.
He laid Simmons’ body down on the gurney
and watched with glee as the robotic arm lowered
towards him.
It reached into his chest and pulled out the
essence of one three-sided threat to reality:
Bill Cipher.
One quick journey through the bowels of the
machine later, the nightmare scenario had
come to pass - Bill floated around the room,
dragged into physical reality.
He let out a long, conceited cackle and spun
his cane around.
This was going to be fun!
Elsewhere in the facility, alarms were going
off, and guards were deploying.
Nobody was meant to be in containment chamber
158, so how was the soul extractor currently
operating?
This couldn’t possibly end well...
Bill, on the other hand, was having a wonderful
time.
He was pondering all the different ways he
could make the drab, clinical corridors of
the SCP Foundation into his vision of perfect
weirdness.
Maybe he’d turn all the researchers into
mice and turn Site 19 into a giant maze to
run them through.
Maybe he’d turn the air into farts and release
winged beasts from the hell dimension to ravage
humanity.
Maybe he’d go out to the parking lot and
key everyone’s cars.
Oh, the diabolical possibilities were endless!
As he floated out into the hall, his fantasizing
was interrupted by a group of Foundation Security
Operatives wielding assault rifles.
They entered an attack formation and trained
their rifles on him, before opening fire.
Bill just found himself laughing again - The
gunfire just tickled!
“Wow, you guys are hilarious!”
Bill said between peals of laughter.
“But wait, I can think of a way to make
you even funnier!”
He snapped his fingers, and suddenly, the
guards were transformed.
Instead of the serious first line of defense
for the SCP Foundation, they were now a gang
of literal clowns straight from the circus,
holding balloon animals molded into the shapes
of assault rifles.
They giggled and threw pies at each other.
Bill was right; this did make them even funnier.
And he was just getting started, turning this
Foundation snoozefest into a party of cosmic
proportions!
Bill began running a rampage of weirdness
across the site.
Essentially being the ultimate cosmic troll,
he decided he’d simply bother every single
anomaly he could with his demonic antics.
First, he appeared in SCP-096’s chamber
and pulled a brown paper bag over his head,
with the words “UGLINESS LIES WITHIN”
written on the front.
And just for fun, he then teleported the temperamental
beast to a nearby Amish community.
It quickly became enraged when a gust of wind
blew the bag off its head, and a man named
Jedediah saw its face.
It then killed several others, also named
Jedediah, during the rampage.
Bill thought it was hilarious.
He then released SCP-682 into Site 19 and,
just to annoy the creature into further violence,
he stuck an indestructible party hat on the
monster’s head.
No matter how hard 682 tried, it couldn’t
remove the party hat.
This caused it great frustration, which it
took out on any Foundation staff it happened
to find in the area.
It had fulfilled Bill’s expectations wonderfully,
but his quest for amusing carnage didn’t
end there.
Next, he went to bother SCP-049, the Plague
Doctor, who was in the process of doing surgery
on a Foundation-provided dead goat.
With a snap of his fingers, Bill transformed
the Plague Doctor’s surgical tools into
colorful Play-Doh cutting tools.
Needless to say, the supernatural surgeon
was less than pleased.
He was about as annoyed as Dr. Clef was when
Bill turned his favorite shotgun into a bouquet
of flowers, then sealed his feet into the
floor, or how vexed Dr. Gears was when Bill
turned his plain beige necktie into a considerably
more loud and colorful tie.
People there at the time reported hearing
Dr. Gears say, “I just don’t think that
was necessary.”
Oh, and he also did some more minor acts of
malice: He filled the break room with an army
of flesh-eating zombies, he made a moat filled
with molten lava around the site that prevented
anyone from escaping from his reign of terror,
and he even covered all the walls in cognitohazardous
doodles that instantly drove any weak-minded
human who saw them into complete, gibbering
madness.
It was clear this reality-warping nightmare
needed to be stopped before he got bored of
playing with his new Foundation toys and decided
to go remodel the universe in his own image.
Thankfully, there was one anomaly on site
who was up to the task.
Bill was treating himself to another evil
laugh in the Site 19 canteen when something
peculiar happened.
He looked down to see a man in what looked
like a tunic with greying hair and a beard.
He walked with a peculiar kind of calmness,
his face blank.
Why wasn’t this guy panicking?
Was he stupid?
Bill would seemingly need to teach this guy
a thing or two about fear...
“Hey, gramps, don’t know if it’s escaped
your attention, but I’ve been giving this
place an extreme makeover!”
Bill yelled.
“Did you forget to put on your glasses this
morning, or are you just that senile?”
The stranger remained calm as could be.
He replied with a voice that was measured
as it was deep, “Now, Bill, let’s not
resort to name calling.
That’s just childish, don’t you think?”
Bill’s single eye widened at this.
“Wait, Wait, hold up.
How do you know my name?”
Bill asked, irritated.
“Are you a friend of the Time Baby or something?”
He floated over and began circling the stranger,
hoping to intimidate him.
Much to Bill’s frustration, it didn’t
appear to be working.
“I know lots of things, Bill, lots of things,”
the stranger replied.
“That’s my line!”
Bill screeched, turning red.
“Who do you think you are?”
The stranger gave a quiet, reserved chuckle
that infuriated Bill.
“Oh, personally, I just like to think of
myself as a humble craftsman, watching his
beautiful creation play out,” he said.
“But I suppose some of the people around
here like to call me God.”
Bill didn’t like this.
This whole universe was going to be his, and
he certainly didn’t appreciate some insolent
old man acting like he ran the roost around
here.
Bill would give him an education in who was
really holding the reins - and it would be
the kind of education that left scars, if
it left anything at all.
He extended his spindly black arms and released
bolts of lightning against the stranger, who
simply continued to smile as the electricity
rippled around him, seemingly causing no effect.
“Are you done?”
the stranger asked.
Bill laughed, hoping to hide his irritation.
“I’m just getting started!”
He bellowed.
With a thunderous roar that shook the very
foundations of Site 19, Bill began to grow
and shift.
No longer a silly little triangle, he became
a huge, red pyramid of pure nightmares, covered
in glowing golden arms and teeth, with long,
black tongues drooping out of each level.
It was the most terrifying and demonic form
in his entire arsenal, and yet, he was astonished
to find that the stranger still didn’t seem
to show any kind of fear.
“Very impressive, Bill,” the stranger
said, sounding almost bored.
“But I think you might be trying a little
too hard.”
Oh, that does it; Bill would simply have to
destroy him.
It was a matter of pride now.
He raised several of his huge, golden fists
and began pounding down on the comparatively
tiny, humanoid stranger.
It was an assault so powerful that the ground
began cracking around their feet.
And yet, it seemed that with almost no effort,
the stranger was able to intercept and block
every single blow.
Naturally, Bill was infuriated.
It was time to finally unleash the full breadth
of his power on this beardy wise guy.
He launched thunderbolts, fireballs, legions
of giant, mutant wasps, hailstorms, maelstroms,
bubbles of pure madness, snakes made of barbed
wire, and even incredible coarse language.
But despite it all, this man - the one who
claimed people call him God - was utterly
unfazed.
“You can dish it out,” he said.
“But let’s see if you can take it.”
Bill began to laugh.
“What the heck is that supposed to mean?
You can’t—“
God snapped his fingers, and Bill was gone.
Vanished.
And with a flick of his wrist, all the damage
and transformations that Bill had performed
had disappeared.
It was as though the demonic triangle had
never even been there in the first place.
Though Dr. Bright, who was acting Site Director
at the time, had some Scranton Reality Anchors
turned on around the perimeter, just to be
safe.
You can never be too careful with reality-warping
demons, after all.
Later that day, Dr. Bright approached God,
and asked him what he’d actually done with
Bill.
God chuckled and replied, “For a being of
such immense power, he really had a rather
childish mindset, so I sealed him away inside
a children’s cartoon, where he couldn’t
do any further damage.”
“What was the cartoon?”
Dr. Bright asked.
“A charming little Disney show called Gravity
Falls,” God replied.
Now go check out “Your Questions for God
Answered” and “SCP-096 VS SCP-343” for
more of this singularly unique reality warper!